[Música]
El capitán monkey de Luffy ha tenido un
camino difícil lleno de retos y un
montón de enemigos después de todo para
convertirte en el rey de los mares de
vez en cuando no queda de otra que
aventarte madrazos con todo el mundo
para que sepan quién
manda es por eso que a lo largo de toda
la serie Luffy ha tenido que ir
evolucionando constantemente y
volviéndose cada vez más fuerte para
poder seguir su camino de convertirse en
el rey de los piratas y es que en
realidad Luffy Puede que sea un [__]
la mayor parte del tiempo pero cuando se
trata de romperse la cara con sus
enemigos Te sorprendería lo inteligente
que puede llegar a ser
ingeniármelas
poco en el anime y poco a poco nos
estamos enterando de todos los jugosos
secretos del mundo de One Piece Por qué
no aprovechar este momento para dar un
recorrido por toda la evolución que ha
tenido El capitán a lo largo de los
últimos 25 años Qué buena historia sentí
que estuve ahí la verdad es que siempre
quise hacer un video sobre One Piece
pero no me había terminado de leer todo
el manga antes y no estaba al día con el
anime Pero eso cambió pues usando una
cantidad totalmente razonable de tiempo
me comí toda la serie entera y ahora
estoy al día con el manga y voy por wano
en el anime por lo que ahora sí me
siento con la infinita sabiduría como
para dedicarle el video que se merece
One Piece obviamente es hora decirlo
pero este video estará lleno de spoilers
de toda la serie por lo que si te
quieres adelantar de los más de 1000
capítulos primero y luego Volver al
video aquí te espero de otra manera
Vamos a darle un vistazo a la evolución
del futuro rey de los piratas con todas
las transformaciones de monkey de
[Música]
Luffy
dio Comencemos desde lo más básico
monkey de Luffy es un joven pirata hijo
del hombre más buscado del mundo monkey
Dragon y de su mamá además es Nieto del
poderoso hogar Así que llevan la sangre
sue agarrarse a puñetazos con cualquiera
en su niñez se hizo muy amigo del yonko
shanks y en uno de sus descuidos Luffy
se comió la fruta del [__] que le
habían robado al gobierno la gomu gomu
nomi lo que lo convirtió en un humano de
goma ganando de inmediato la habilidad
de estirar cualquier y digo cualquier
parte de su cuerpo pero como todo
usuario de fruta del [__] tiene la
desventaja de que ya no puede nadar
estas habilidades hacen que Luffy sea
invulnerable a la electricidad a las
balas y a la mayoría de ataques físicos
pues su cuerpo de goma solo los
absorbe Aunque pueda sonar algo ridícula
la habilidad de ser un humano de goma y
no nos vamos a engañar hasta cierto
punto lo es Luffy ha demostrado una
inmensa creatividad y ha logrado darle
unos usos increíbles a su cuerpo de goma
que lo han hecho pelear cara aa quea con
los piratas más fuertes del mundo sé que
no se ve como un gran peleador y de
hecho se ve flaco como una lombriz pero
en realidad él tiene una gran fuerza
física y una resistencia rayando en lo
absurdo los ataques de Luffy son
demasiados como para nombrar en un video
pero su Estilo de pelea se basa en
ataques en los que estira partes de su
cuerpo para ganar impulso y fuerza
adicional y golpear a sus enemigos con
un poderoso impacto resultando de hecho
bastante efectivo inicialmente Aunque
que siendo bastante fuerte Luffy peleaba
de manera simple golpeando sus enemigos
sin parar y esperando que uno de estos
golpes los dejara tiesos pero con el
pasar del tiempo Luffy mejoraría su
Estilo de pelea y comenzaría a usar sus
habilidades con más eficacia y control
Además de que eventualmente él
aprendería a usar múltiples tipos de
haki que lo volverían bastante roto
tiene el haki de observación que no solo
le da una percepción aumentada de todo a
su alrededor sino que también en su
forma avanzada le otorga la habilidad de
ver un par de segundos en el futuro
tiene haki de armadura avanzado que es
como una armadura natural que además de
pegar muy fuerte le permite causarle
daños internos a sus enemigos y
finalmente el haki más poderoso el haki
del Rey una habilidad que inicialmente
solo manifestaba la imponente fuerza de
voluntad de Luffy y causaba que
cualquier persona sin la fuerza
necesaria se desmayara ante su presencia
pero en el arco de wano Luffy aprendió a
infundir todos sus ataques con el haki
del Rey aumentando enormemente su poder
y de hecho haciendo posible golpear a un
enemigo sin siquiera tocarlo tocándome
está tocándome no estoy tocándote no
estás tocándome a día de hoy monkey de
Luffy es ahora uno de los cuatro
emperadores del mar y aún en su estado
base tiene más que suficientes trucos
para romperte la madre si no lo tomas en
[Música]
serio luego de entrenar incansable
emente con Mike Tyson y Mohammed Ali
Luffy llegaría a la cúspide de su poder
logrando una transformación que lo
volvería tan fuerte como para que kaido
le haga Los mandados y ese es afrol
Luffy hermoso el cabrón eh durante el
mini arco del David Back Fight ese en
donde hacen una especie de torneo para
ver quién se queda con los compañeros de
quién Luffy debe pelear contra foxy en
un uno pa uno sin camiseta para
recuperar a sus compañeros Así que
mientras su soplo entrena a pararle en
toda su madre a foxy ambos ven una
peluca con estilo afro y quedan tan
encantados que deciden que no solo se le
vería genial A Luffy sino que esta le
daría habilidades excepcionales en el
boxeo en realidad no lo hace y lo único
que logra es que Luffy tenga un glorioso
afro durante la pelea Pero sería un
pecado dejar a afro Luffy fuera de la
lista Pero Ey las risas no faltaron
eh Para hacer un shen Luffy logró llegar
bastante lejos sin necesitar
transformaciones o Power Ups Pero eso
cambiaría en water 7 y Es que luego de
que okii y el cp9 le dieran sus
pataditas a los mugiwara Luffy se dio
cuenta de que con su poder actual no
lograría proteger a nadie por lo que su
Ingenio salió a flote y basándose en las
técnicas del cp9 que logró analizar
mientras peleaba con ellos Luffy crearía
la segunda
marcha en esta transformación Luffy
aprovecha la flexibilidad de su cuerpo
de goma y la usa para bombear más sangre
a todo su cuerpo y así obtener toda la
energía oxígeno y nutrientes mucho más
rápido este aumento en la presión
arterial en Luffy causa que toda su piel
se torne de un color rojizo casi rosado
además debido a que su metabolismo se
vuelve extremadamente rápido todo el
sudor que produce Se evapora
instantáneamente por lo que su cuerpo
está constantemente envuelto en vapor
cada vez que usa la segunda marcha
gracias a estos cambios Luffy gana un
aumento bastante grande en su fuerza
agilidad y sobre todo en su velocidad a
pesar de ser su primera transformación
la verdad es que le salió bastante bien
pues en su pelea contra blueno le rompe
el hocico sin que él ni siquiera se dé
cuenta de qué está pasando al principio
su segunda marcha tenía una gran
desventaja pues al haber desarrollado
Esta técnica tan rápido y no haber
tenido tiempo para que su cuerpo la
asimile no solo termina agotado luego de
usarla sino que el mismo Luci teoriza
que al usar esta habilidad
Luffy pierde años de vida
afortunadamente para el sombrero de paja
estas desventajas desaparecen luego del
Times skip Al haber entrenado todas sus
habilidades con Riley por lo que
actualmente Luffy puede usar Esta
técnica en cualquier momento y sin mucho
esfuerzo además de poder combinarla con
sus múltiples tipos de haki para hacer
cosas bien locas como recubrir sus
ataques con fuego y haki de armadura
para hacer un daño inmenso Y cómo es que
puede hacer eso bueno Ya llegaré emos
ahí al mismo tiempo que desarrolló su
segunda marcha Luffy no se quedó ahí y
decidió inventarse otro poder en caso de
que el primero le fallara creando
también la tercera marcha en esta forma
Luffy le inyecta aire a sus huesos y lo
dirige a cualquier parte de su cuerpo
creando ataques en los que ya sean sus
puños o sus piernas se vuelven tan
grandes y fuertes como los de un gigante
esta marcha es bastante simple infl
parte de su cuerpo puño más grande puño
más fuerte pero aunque sea simple
Resulta ser bastante efectiva pues hace
que todo los ataques de Luffy tengan una
fuerza inmensa Además de que su gran
tamaño hace que su alcance también
aumente por lo que se ha mostrado en la
serie Esta técnica solo puede ser usada
en una parte del cuerpo a la vez y no es
como si pudiera inflar todo su cuerpo y
convertirse en gigante Pero puede que
Luffy en este punto ya pueda usarla de
maneras más creativas al principio de la
la serie usar esta habilidad tenía una
gran consecuencia Y es que luego de ser
usada Luffy se volvería chiquito por un
par de segundos mientras recuperaba su
fuerza dejándolo bastante debilitado y
vulnerable a algún Madrazo enemigo
Aunque luego del Times skip su
entrenamiento lo hizo adaptarse más a
todas sus habilidades y ahora puede usar
su tercera marcha bastante seguido Y sin
ninguna consecuencia real y Aunque la
verdad es una habilidad un poco lenta y
algo inconveniente a la hora de pelear
así haciendo uso del haki y de otros
trucos bastante creativos puede llegar a
ser algo muy peligroso para sus
enemigos durante uno de los muchos arcos
de relleno de One Piece Luffy se
encuentra con una chica que tiene la
habilidad de encogerse y volverse
gigante a voluntad y eventualmente todos
los mugiwaras se vuelven bastante amigos
de ella por lo que en la pelea final de
este mini arco como de costumbre a Luffy
le están dando una paliza y obviamente
siendo los personajes de One Piece tan
inteligentes como siempre decidieron que
la única opción para ganar la pelea era
lanzar a esta chica a la boca de Luffy
para que se la trague se agrande dentro
de su panzota y ver qué pasa puede que
Luffy hubiera explotado o se le hubieran
rasgado las tripas
Pero afortunadamente para todos el plan
funcionó y el cuerpo elástico de Luffy
se adaptó al crecimiento de la chica
haciendo que él se convirtiera en un
gigante más Más allá del enorme tamaño
que obtiene por alguna extraña razón se
vuelve mucho más fuerte y resistente
además lo curioso es que aún estando en
esta forma gigante Luffy puede seguir
usando sus demás Gears sin problema
alguno Y lo demuestra usando su segunda
marcha y lanzando un ataque gigante y
veloz para derrotar al Villano este que
ya no me acuerdo cómo se llama al
parecer estar en este estado gigante le
aumenta también el poder a todas sus
demás técnicas pues por ejemplo al
activar la segunda marcha el vapor que
salió de su cuerpo fue tanto y tan
potente que causó olas Gigantes y casi
hunde al mismo Sony a pesar de ser parte
de un arco de relleno y ser algo rara no
deja de ser interesante y algo que valga
la pena
mencionar Esta es una de las
transformaciones o formas de Luffy que
más se olvida o de la que menos se habla
ya sea porque Thriller bark fue uno de
los arcos más flojitos de One Piece o
también porque la mayoría ni siquiera
vieron el arco Sí los estoy viendo a
ustedes perros que se saltaron skypia y
Thriller bark ustedes me dan asco por si
acaso Déjame explicarte de qué Aba todo
esto en la saga de Thriller bark el
Villano principal era geko moria un Nemo
panzón que tenía la habilidad de
arrancarle las Sombras a las personas
para robarle sus habilidades y poder al
final del Arco todo ya estaba bien
[__] con moria reviviendo un zombie
gigante llamado oars y entregándole la
sombra de Luffy moria les había robado
su sombra casi todos Así que tiempo no
era Precisamente lo que tenían por lo
que Lola tuvo la brillante idea de
sobrecargar a Luffy con decenas de
sombras Para que tuviera un Power up
temporal durante toda la saga se
establece que una persona normal solo
aguanta tener dentro de su cuerpo como
máximo dos o tres sombras o de lo
contrario pero Luffy es de todo menos
normal Así que dada su gran fuerza de
voluntad y su enorme resistencia le
pudieron meter 100 sombras a su cuerpo
ganando las habilidades experiencia y
conocimiento de todas y cada una de las
sombras en su interior este incremento
tan repentino de poder hizo que la piel
de Luffy se volviera azul y creciera
bastante en tamaño naciendo así
Nightmare Luffy en este estado Luffy es
capaz de moverse mucho más rápido de lo
usual ganando también una gran cantidad
de fuerza con la que es capaz de detener
los ataques de or sin mucho esfuerzo
lanzarlo de un lado a otro y derrotar lo
rápidamente Más allá de los aumentos
normales como superfuerza y velocidad lo
interesante de esta transformación es
que Luffy gana las habilidades de todas
las sombras que tiene en su interior por
ejemplo una de sus sombras era de un
Samurai muy fuerte por lo que ahora
Luffy sabe muy bien Cómo usar las
espadas y pelea usando una muy grande
Así que Luffy Ahora tiene muchos estilos
de pelea e información a su disposición
Incluso en algunos videojuegos se le
puede ver usando un arco gigante y
lanzando enormes bolas de fuego pero
quién sabe si esto sea Canon o no la
única desventaja es que el estado de
Nightmare Luffy solo dura 10 minutos
después de eso las 100 sombras saldrán
del cuerpo de Luffy y lo dejarán inmóvil
por un rato aún así aunque algo extraña
esta forma me parece las más
[Música]
interesantes después del Times skip
tuvimos un par de arcos en los que el
único punto central era ver como Luffy y
sus amigos barría el piso con sus
enemigos para presumir su nuevo poder
Así que realmente no los vemos tener
mayor problema en sus peleas eso es
hasta que llegamos a dres Rosa en donde
doflamingo apalea a Luffy en múltiples
ocasiones él era un oponente
infinitamente superior en fuerza
inteligencia Y Flow es debido a esta
gran diferencia de poder por la que
Luffy es forzado a usar su nueva técnica
el Gear Ford una transformación que
desarrolló en sus dos años entrenando
con ry aprovechando su reciente dominio
con el
haki aquí Luffy infla sus músculos y a
la vez los recubre con haki creando esta
versión enorme y regordeta de sí mismo a
esta transformación se le llama boundman
mayormente porque el cuerpo de Luffy se
infla tanto que le cuesta caminar
normalmente Así que rebota
constantemente para mantener el
equilibrio y honestamente es mejor
porque se ve bien perturbador cuando cam
normal the puede que se vea chistoso y
todo pero el punto clave de esta
transformación están los putazos
continentales que suelta pues al
combinar el haki de armadura con sus
músculos inflados y sus habilidades de
goma al máximo la fuerza de Luffy
aumenta increíblemente logrando ataques
en los que puede contraer sus puños
patadas y hasta su cabeza dentro de sí
mismo usando la enorme presión del aire
y la tensión que genera en su cuerpo de
goma para lanzar ataques devastadores
además gana habilidades extra como
lanzar puños teledirigidos que pueden
cambiar de dirección a voluntad y poder
volar al patear el aire muy fuerte Como
toda gran transformación esta viene con
un precio y es que Luffy solo puede
usarla por cortos periodos de tiempo
Pues luego de un rato el haki de Luffy
se agota y su cuerpo expulsa todo el
aire acumulado en su interior dejándolo
fuera de combate y completamente
exhausto durante 10 minutos mi mientras
recupera su haki Claro que son solo 10
minutos pero son 10 minutos en los que
casi no se puede mover y su enemigo
puede acercarse y con el pasar del
tiempo parece que Luffy aprendió a
controlar mucho más esta marcha y su
agotamiento ya no es tanto además de
poder usarla por más tiempo y más
eficientemente
aquí hay algo ligeramente complicado El
Gear 4 a pesar de ser una transformación
única de Luffy puede ser modificado de
cambiar para ser usada de diferentes
maneras dependiendo de la situación es
por eso que hasta ahora hemos visto tres
variaciones distintas del el Gear 4 la
primera es la versión original que
vendría siendo la versión de ataque y
Fuerza bruta y la segunda en ser
presentada fue el Gear 4 versión tankman
La verdad es que esta no es una
transformación que lleva un trasfondo
muy grande ni nada por el estilo sucedió
solamente cuando Luffy activó su cuarta
marcha después de haber comido como
puerco Chistosa por es panzón durante su
pelea contra cracker Luffy estaba
abrumado con las habilidades de su
enemigo que le permitían crear soldados
de galletas extremadamente poderosos por
lo que en su infinita sabiduría Luffy
dejó de pelear y comenzó a comerse a
todos los soldados de Dulce quedó tan
lleno que al activar su Gear F la
cualidad más destacable era su enorme
panzota que estaba recubierta con haki
de armadura la cual usó para absorber
los ataques de cracker y lanzarlo a
volar devolviéndole el impacto ahí es
cuando te das cuenta de cuán diferente
es One Piece de otras series mientras
que Goku necesitaba músculos enormes
para madrear a sus enemigos Luffy solo
necesita una panza de hierro y mucha
comida solo hemos visto una vez esta
versión de Luffy pero lo poco que se
sabe es que es bastante resistente al
daño y absorbe mucho impacto Y aunque
técnicamente no funciona muy bien para
pelear Se podría decir que es la versión
de defensa y armadura del Gear 4
al final del arco de hul cake Island
durante más de 20 episodios pudimos ver
como katakuri se madrea a Luffy sin
Piedad alguna pero ya todos sabemos cómo
funciona esto después de haber sido
derribado 3800 veces y tener su cerebro
bien magullado sus poderes de
protagonista entran en acción y Luffy se
pone serio por lo que en la parte
definitiva de la pelea con ambos
cansados y a punto de caer deciden usar
su máximo poder y acabar con est de una
vez por todas el Gear 4 regular no
funcionaba contra katakuri Pues él es
capaz de ver el futuro y predecir todos
sus movimientos por lo que Luffy es
obligado a improvisar Así que usando
todo lo que aprendió durante la pelea y
en su entrenamiento con Riley Luffy nos
revela el Gear for
snakeman
sn Esta es la última versión conocida
del Gear 4 aquí Luffy sacrifica una gran
parte de su fuerza ferza de ataque y su
defensa para ganar una increíble
velocidad siendo lo suficientemente
Rápido como para lograr golpear a
katakuri quien aún teniendo la habilidad
de ver en el futuro no podía
esquivarlo A diferencia de las otras
variaciones aquí Luffy no engorda ni se
pone tan mamado aquí de hecho se ve
bastante delgado y ligeramente más
grande en tamaño pero que no te engañe
su apariencia flacucha pues aún tiene
fuerza de sobra al igual que el Gear 4
regular Luffy puede cambiar
constantemente la dirección de sus
ataques para cargarlos con más fuerza y
hacerlos impredecibles dando golpes
tanto fuertes como instantáneos a pesar
de contar con gran fuerza y una
velocidad abismal Lo único malo de esta
variación es que al concentrarse tanto
en la velocidad Luffy abandona su
defensa por lo que es más susceptible a
los golpes y recibe mucho más daño en
sus peleas en resumen el Gear for se
divide en tres variantes la original la
versión Man que es la versión de fuerza
y ataque la versión tankman que es la de
defensa y la versión snakeman que es la
de velocidad y poder explosivo y la que
mejor se ve es un
papucho Bueno aquí Tenemos que hablar
bastante porque muchas de las cosas que
sucedieron en wano Y en especial el Gear
Five cambiaron todo lo que conocíamos
sobre Luffy Así que pon atención durante
su infinita pelea contra kaido
onigashima kaido le mete un Madrazo a
Luffy que lo deja al borde de la muerte
pero cuando estaba a punto de irse con
Dios sus latidos comienzan a sonar con
más fuerza con un sonido que el mismo
sunesa describe como los tambores de la
liberación y es estando casi muerto que
Luffy finalmente logra El Despertar De
su fruta del [__] y El Dios del sol
renace resulta que todo lo que nos
venían contando Durante los últimos 20
años era mentira y ahora se le olvidó
avisarnos en realidad la fruta de Luffy
nunca fue la gomu gomun nomi Ese fue un
nombre que el gobierno mundial se
inventó para esconderle al mundo entero
la verdad detrás de esta legendaria
fruta la verdadera fruta de Luffy es la
zoan mitológica hito hitomi modelon nika
una kuman omi tan peligrosa y poderosa
que el gobierno mundial ha tratado
durante siglos de conseguirla pero
siempre ha fallado mediante el despertar
Luffy logra desbloquear la verdadera
naturaleza de su fruta y acceder a todo
su poder completo lo que lo convierte en
la Encarnación de nika El Dios del Sol y
el Guerrero de la liberación físicamente
la apariencia de Luffy cambia un montón
en esta forma pues su ropa y cabello se
vuelven completamente blancos y sus ojos
se tornan de un color rojizo además de
estar constantemente emanando haki y por
alguna razón poder hacer cosas raras
como las de los loney tuns pero lo
interesante del Gear Five son sus
habilidades Y es que las habilidades
reales de esta fruta sí le otorgan a su
usuario propiedades similares a los de
La goma lo que hizo que Luffy durante
mucho tiempo pensara que ese era su
único poder pero una vez despertada su
fruta su verdadero potencial radica en
su creatividad pues su usuario ahora
podría volver realidad cualquier cosa de
su imaginación siendo capaz de usarla
como un arma ahora esto no quiere decir
que Luffy pueda imaginarse un agujero
negro y sacárselo de los huevos no O por
lo menos no por ahora con lo que se nos
ha mostrado sus poderes Aunque rotísimo
tienen límites con lo de la imaginación
me refiero a que puede pelear como se le
dé la gana siempre y cuando su mente se
lo permita hay varios ejemplos en la
serie como cuando Luffy le dio un puño a
los ojos de kaido Y en vez de romps elos
los hizo estirarse con sus manos o
cuando literalmente materializó unas
gafas de la absoluta nada Debería ser
posible Claro que no pero Exactamente
eso es lo que lo hace tan poderoso
pensar en las cosas más extrañas
posibles y hacerlas realidad no por nada
se le llama al poder más ridículo del
mundo saber que su único límite de su
imaginación de hecho explica muchas
cosas de One Piece como el hecho de que
de un momento a otro Luffy pudiera crear
fuego de sus manos para atacar porque
porque sí como mencioné antes El
Despertar hace que Luffy esté
constantemente emitiendo su poderoso
haki además de darle un montón de
habilidades nuevas dentro de las cuales
están agarrar rayos con sus manos para
tirarlos o impulsarse con ellos
convertirse en un gigante mucho más
grande que el mismo kaido ser casi
invulnerable a la mayoría de daño
alterar su entorno para volverlo similar
a La goma y lanzar ataques del tamaño de
una [__] Isla todas estas habilidades
hacen que el estilo de pelea de Luffy se
vuelva bastante caótico y use formas muy
creativas para derrotar a sus enemigos
desafortunadamente el despertar de una
fruta del [__] es algo muy difícil de
conseguir y Por ende es algo que pone
mucho estrés sobre el cuerpo de Luffy
por lo que si lo usa por demasiado
tiempo su cuerpo sufrirá las
consecuencias y rápidamente se quedará
sin fuerzas esta de momento es la última
y más poderosa transformación que Luffy
nos ha enseñado y A mi parecer una de
las mejores que tiene su tono
caricaturesco rozando lo ridículo encaja
muy bien con el tono de One Piece y con
Luffy en general como personaje el Gear
Five es la cúspide de las múltiples
transformaciones que ha tenido Luffy y
que poco a poco lo han llevado un paso
más cerca de convertirse en el rey de
los
piratas es algo curioso que One Piece
aún siendo una de las series más largas
que hay tiene relativamente pocas
transformaciones en comparación a las de
ichigo Naruto o Goku pero aquí tienes el
recorrido entero por más de 25 años de
historia que algú un día le podrás
contar a tus nietos Claro si One Piece
termina algún día Hay que respetar la
creatividad de oda al hacer
transformaciones tan únicas y fuera de
lo convencional para sus personajes
puedes decir lo que quieras sobre sus
diseños o muchas de las cosas que hace
pero lo que le sobra al tipo es
creatividad recientemente oda reveló que
planea acabar One Piece dentro de poco
pero ya sabemos que en el lenguaje de
ichir oda poco significa por lo menos
otros 3 años así y que aún queda espacio
para que Luffy y los mugiwara tengan
otro poquito de desarrollo y podamos ver
Con qué tipo de poderes locos nos pueden
sorprender ahora Así que si pasa ya nos
veremos de nuevo aquí por ahora esas son
todas las transformaciones del futuro
rey de los piratas la verdad le agarré
bastante cariño a One Piece pero me tomó
un largo tiempo ver la serie completa y
ponerme al día con todas sus locuras Así
que apreciarías si apoyas este video no
sé si alcance a editar y subir este
video en 2023 o a principios de
2024 Pero espero que no sea tarde para
desearles una feliz navidad un feliz año
nuevo y agradecerles a todos por el
enorme apoyo que me han mostrado Espero
que podamos seguir creciendo este 2024 y
que podamos seguir divirtiéndonos hasta
la
próxima
[Música]
se